alors ici on se trouve sur le sur la 23e
rue au ray lane au coeur de chelsea
tient un grand quartier résidentiel à
new york et donc le high line c'est cet
ancien mais cette ancienne ligne
ferroviaire qui a été transformée en un
parc moderne est extrêmement populaire
et cette création elle a été possible
c'est un partenariat entre la ville de
new york est une fondation privée frendo
brennan qui a la gestion du parc la
ville a mis en place des financements
pour la rénovation d'une delà de cette
ligne ferroviaire abandonné et friends
of earth and a mis en place tout un
programme de design pour ce parc est
maintenant s'occupe de la gestion du
parc au jour le jour
une gestion qui bénéficie à près de 6
millions de visiteurs par an